are luke bryan and blake shelton
friends i'll hell with this i'm not
doing
hey gq i'm luke bryan and i'm going
undercover on the internet
this is actually me
instagram
[Music]
atlanta not lena atlanta brian three
which is my wife
you guys are the best you should have
your own television show
i would definitely watch that i wonder
what it would be called well
i've got banana shorts on so let's call
it bananas
at the brines brines go bananas
anyway that's weird let's just say
no reality show ever
posted
[Music]
katie it's katie turner from american
idol you're not
fooling me on that one can i listen to
one margarita
even if i'm under 21. you can certainly
listen to one margarita if you're under
21 because
my children it's their favorite song and
they're 12
and 9. parents i'm sorry
for you having to explain to your
children
the sequence of margaritas followed by a
shot
my bad
[Music]
becky p do they think you're still cool
enjoy it while you can
my boys think i'm pretty cool during the
summers i love to come out on the road
and
sit sidestage and throw guitar picks at
me
they're still 12 and 9 so when they're
14
15 i will not be cool submit
twitter
[Music]
trish h malone i was listening to your
song do
i earlier today i've always wondered who
or what inspires you to write your songs
they are so good well trish the funny
thing about do
i is it was a song about a relationship
that was kind of on the rocks and
there's so many
things in life that inspires you to
write songs i mean just getting up in
the day
things your kids say being outside just
life experiences i mean the best way to
get inspired writing songs is get out
there and live every day and live life
up
next jennifer burke at breyer underscore
rose
questions i ponder after drinking a lot
of bullet
hey luke bryan how does a dandelion
dance a dandelion you know dances in the
wind and
what do you even call the dandelion
little things that when you were a kid
you would blow the anyway
i think you know what i mean
[Laughter]
little rock at simple rock
i love these names at luke bryan quick
question
why do you got band-aids on your fingers
well i think you're referring to when we
were
recording american idol from my home
i had decided to make homemade hush
puppies
and when i dropped the hush puppy the
grease flew up and burnt
all three fingers i literally had to
sleep that night with my hand
and a cup of ice thanks for the concern
my fingers are beat up anyway posted
lee at alabama hannah at luke bryan
what's the best
fish you've ever caught right when i
moved to nashville i bought a boat
and i towed it all the way down to my
hometown
and put it in at 32 bridge and right
below 32 bridge i caught about a
7 pound 11 ounce shoal bass
which the world record is eight two so i
almost
broke the world record with my show bass
and that was my favorite fish i've ever
caught
this is a good twitter name positivity
brings out the good in life
at luke bryan online this might be a
weird question but have you ever watched
people
covering your songs on youtube yeah i
mean i've seen some good performances
through the years and i've actually seen
some people
do a better job than me so it's always
flattering when people
are performing your songs on youtube
cora
[Music]
are blake shelton and luke bryan friends
ah
hell i'm not answering that because
we're not
just playing blake and i are really
really good friends i mean we've always
had a
very great mutual respect for one
another and when we were able to host
the acms
together we really just became even
closer
and we've done some hunting trips
together and anytime i can be around
blake we have a great time
submit if luke bryan had a catch phrase
what would it be goofiness pays off
another catch phrase is uh yep we'll get
it handled that means i'm ready to hang
up the phone i'm tired of talking about
my career
can i have luke bryan make an appearance
at my home
if the money's right
what kind of guitar does luke bryan play
i play electric and acoustic on stage
when i play electric
it's either a paul reed smith or a
fender telecaster
and then i play mostly gibsons and
bourgeois
guitars acoustics next
would you beat luke bryan in a fist
fight so is this like
fight club or something where i beat up
myself i would hope
i would beat myself up in a fist fight
because i know my weaknesses and
i know where to target and all that
[Music]
youtube
[Music]
alexis v l-o-l why is luke bryan so
obsessed
with spring break well as you grow older
in life
the best way to stay young is still
party at spring break like you're 20.
[Music]
imdb
height six foot and one half inch
false six two barefooted six
two cowboy boots six three and a half
next luke and his wife caroline bryan
were college sweethearts
true met in a bar posted
all right gq that's it i'm signing off
the internet
love y'all